okay think we're
live
hi we are not on
Windows uh yesterday turned out to be a
whole
mess in which we found that WSL was
messing up a ton of
stuff and I had to wipe the machine and
set this up so I'm back now
uh I'm going to have to set up a few
things on the Fly
here but hopefully we can get some more
Dev done
today so first of all let me figure out
how to get the chat onto
here uh we have
chat hang on OBS is being weird
um oh yeah okay I can see it's
working let me get the chat onto the uh
let me get the chat onto the
screen
something here's
chat I move myself of
so I should be able to see that
now and uh just in case I will have
backup
chat on my side monitor
perfect
so I haven't heard much from
Spencer uh in the last couple of
days oh no wait here
is
yesterday it's got a sweep to look
at puffer
go is this
running just doesn't have enough
experiments yet but it has a couple
already with win rate one so I think
we're going to have a good go Base Line
pretty soon here
bed is still working on Enduro need some
work
there uh I could probably do the triple
Triad Baseline right now cuz we have
pong breakout Connect 4 these are
already done snake we might want to look
at a little bit as well today
it trains already
um but yeah let's take a quick look at
probably these two Ms might even want to
just start with snake to finish this
off
o you have like
default a bunto
terminal therea
quick way to
do to do
this that's
how do you mute the
terminal a whatever I don't think it
comes through on the stream
anyways my mic should be working right
oh it's got a bunch of noise in the
background that's probably annoying as
hell let me add noise
suppressor hang
on okay there
new machine had to reset up all of
OBS Okay
okay that's going to drive me crazy hold
on it's beeping every time
I and just do this
right yeah there we
config yeah let's not do that I think it
was
144 and then like 24 or
something there we go
so now what we got to do is look at
snake uh let's start on
that
snake upper
works
right need to get API key off of w b
key and I think we're going to get a
really nice snake demo on it we should
try to get these actually uploaded as
well I think and just get these on to
the
website so that we have the final demos
live because after that pretty much once
all the demos are set and live um it's
just like a bunch of Polish and clean up
and we're ready to launch I guess also
checking the
docks it just tends to drag on for a
while because you know you want to make
sure everything is good to go
display this should not happen on auntu
I don't think
forwarding this is going to be a little
clunky until I get used to the new
what is wrong
with our Docker
let's
see it even do anything or is it just
screwing with
me
interesting being added to your Access
Control
list I imagine does that do anything
slow oh that actually
worked
so there are a few things I need to
decide here I need to decide what
version of the snake en I want to
display uh there's technically yeah you
can see them right here there is a
yellow snake that if I hold shift I can
take control
of I
believe I guess it doesn't work in this
demo at the moment I'll check on why
that is um but you're supposed to always
have one snake that you can take control
over
I think this is probably
the a nice demo to go
with I don't know if this is actually
the Baseline model that was trained I
think it was trained on a slightly
different Map
size um but this is good it's frozen
because uh there's like the limit on the
step coun or
okay so snake is actually good to go for
that
demo triple Triad I think is not good to
go though
right I don't think that there's
actually
a triple Triad Baseline and I don't
think Spencer's been doing that yet
either I think he's on
go
uh yeah so he's just doing G so we'll
go uh yeah so he's just doing G so we'll do triple Triad for
do triple Triad for
him cuz this one doesn't have a baseline
yet I think all the other ones are
pretty much good
end looks like there's no policy loaded
in
fine what stats get reported we get
episode return length and
here this might literally just need a
hyper pram sweep and that's it
for score yeah I think that this is all
it
needs it needs to be told to Max
maximize
score be given a little bit of leeway on
step
count uh I don't actually know how fast
this trains with the defaults let's
check that really
fast yeah nearly million steps a
second you're so early
[Music]
today yeah hold on this is I got the
chat way too big here don't I welcome
by we'll do like what 400
400 does that make it more
reasonable yeah cuz then when I resize
it it looks
good obligatory Star
Puffer please do star the puffer it
really helps when you start the
repository oh we got quite a few folks
on YouTube at the moment
welcome what we're doing at the moment
here is uh we are going to try to train
a baseline for this triple Triad
environment here uh we're going to run a
quick hyper parameter sweep we're going
to set that up and then we're probably
going to start deploying all the other
baselines that we have to the website
I'm going to think a little bit about
some of the C policies and the way I'm
doing that not going to think too hard
about that though uh and we'll go from
there there so I can see that this
environment here it is training but it
takes quite a while so I think I'm going
to set this sweep to be from like 100
million to 500 million it's very very
fast it trains nearly a million steps
per
second uh I'm trying to think if I want
to
do I could make this roughly 10% Faster
by doubling the number of
environments I don't know if I want to
do that
I think we'll just go like this from
here so add pump big
well yeah my camera just totally stopped
for no reason didn't it
that's lovely hang on a second
folks this is a new
setup there will be some Growing
Pains this is also the cheaper
camera have the better version of it po
Alto there we
go camera's good I'd like to put it back
farther I might go get my like the ring
light setup that I had in uh Paulo Alto
because there's not really good Lighting
in this room either I did get the green
screen so I literally have I don't have
an office here I just have like a pretty
sizable bedroom so I have behind me
there's a bed and then the foot of the
bed is just a giant green screen and
then there's my
desk uh I had I set this to cash that
should not happen hold
uh there
is much code
grind but I wanted to do more stuff on
stream so I figured I'd make it
work uh I am going to have to get
credentials for this though like okay I
didn't expect to have to deal with all
of this this stuff
um I I really didn't expect to have to
deal with all this stuff but let me tell
you what happened which is why I wasn't
streaming yesterday so I'm doing some
work for some folks uh that involves
just like you know the basic stuff that
I do for the puffer boxes and all of our
Hardware um so I was just checking on
like hey what are we going to do for New
Hardware setups right like if I wanted
to order boxes now what would I do just
that type of stuff really really simple
right
and uh I was doing perf test on this box
that I bought for my own usage which has
an AMD chip so I was
testing uh I was testing if it's like if
the AMD chips are any
better and I was getting absolutely
terrible results like it was like 20 30%
slower which made no sense and it drove
me nuts all morning
drove me nuts all morning and then
eventually I figured like you know it
might just be WSL right and then I had
all these problems with Windows I
couldn't get the partitions to work so I
just said you know what screw it uh
we're going to try just like standard
auntu setup I stuck auntu on it for like
five minutes just like a live install I
ran the perf test and immediately
everything was way
better and then dur directly after that
I shut the machine off wiped windows and
just stuck in a bun to install on it and
said all right we're done we're going
back to Linux desktops I'm sick of this
mess and it's actually it's been very
nice so far it's been very very nice the
only thing is uh the steam library for
after hours is very
restricted but uh I don't have much time
for that anyways so no big
I'm literally forgetting the name of the
thing that we
scale all right
so scil scale up
click just do
this and then it logs you into
tailet just uses your Google account or
whatever login
successful now all I do as far as a
puffer
box and it should just be that easy
see yeah the boxes are all
up that always works on Windows to be
fair uh I see my own
machine maybe it's just taking taking oh
there it is it just took a second to uh
the first time authentication that's
fine okay and that's it no more annoying
authentication it's literally that's it
you just get SSH access to
boxes
um okay let's pull our pams down so now
we have all of our nice pams let's just
installed and then we will uh we'll give
the sweep a couple
minutes and we'll go do other stuff
while that's happening I'll take like an
hour to get some demos added to the
website uh we'll show the process
of putting compi of compiling C demo
plus neural net applications for web and
sticking those on the website then we'll
have all the newest versions there for
all the ones that we currently have
baselines and that'll be good thing for
the morning uh link also I would have
been on streaming like an hour and a
half before but I had some uh some
stream work to
do we're on a pretty tight schedule
these
KX
Triad back
native uh and it's actually not going to
be mode train it's actually mode sweep
carbs sweep the carbs
this what version of the code do I have
here packing to move quite busy yeah
yeah I know you are you're
good uh
I'm trying to remember I did some stuff
here I don't know where these changes
went
actually because I I had this stuff set
up uh
yeah this is
so there's some stuff with the hyper
pram algorithm at the moment that we're
still trying to figure
out clip
coefficient there should definitely be a
clip
yeah oh yeah we don't want any of this
mess to be
honest Max grad Norm really don't need
any of these
I will say the uh the one non I guess
you can kind of call it RL in a
way
uh is it
so the
[Music]
one just while I'm waiting for this to
make sure this
works I refined the
recipe I reinforcement learned so I this
is an experiment I've been doing for
this week uh I'm trying to find like a
really good high energy High prot 1,000
calorie breakfast
mug uh and now on V4 I've mostly gotten
it to the point that it's
decent mostly gotten it to the point
that it's
decent here's
current there you
go it's just hot chocolate but it has
1,000 calories and 7 76 g of
protein okay this appears to be sweeping
correctly
that okay so here we get score return
and
everything and we'll let this run
handful of experiments for
us I'll just stick this on the other
monitor so next order of business I
think is going to be to update all of
the
policies uh for the various different
environments now I've been trying to
think if I want to automate
this in some
way I don't really think so it's pretty
easy as is well I think that it's too
much to try to like
automate all the compilation stuff cuz
it's it is really pretty easy as is here
I'll show
you have M script in on here no I need
to get M script
this for some reason I think you don't
just clone M script in right isn't there
a there's a setup to it or
something and then it's linked on the
main page
get it is just
this
cool so we are going to um we have the
neuromat policies ported to see we're
just going
to um
upload as a single bundle the
environment the neural net policy and
the weights and why does my camera keep
freezing is that a
thing I might have to get a new camera
okay now we have we're ready to compile
so we should just be able to
do we have this gript set up right here
with all the flags that we want for
mcrip
in very short just a single
command and let's
do what's one that we're going to know
immediately I guess snake
right yeah snake we should know uh but
we have make sure we have the right
version of the
end so let's compile local
first if I recall this is one of the
ones that lags if you compile it without
bad okay so here's our C file and yeah
it's on this perf test so demo is is
yeah the demo is huge right now so we
want 256
snakes uh what's half of this
640 and then it's 360 I
believe snake length food this also has
to be 496 we quarter
it and I think that's
it if we check
snake yeah this is the three 6 640 360
that's what we said
right yeah so this is
good okay and uh it's going to lag so
I'm going to do build
fast and here we go so this is almost
correct except that we're rendering it a
tiny little resolution where you can't
tell what's going
on uh so I'm going to just
do believe there's a render option right
here
yes this is just going to make it render
double
[Music]
resolution bad
value all right no idea what that was
works
now and here you
go and I actually can control the yellow
snake which is right here
cool only other thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to take the I'm going to take
the text out of
text okay I'm going to take this out
because uh we now have a nice website
for
this 360
[Music]
lines don't need this comment at the
top don't need this
logging another
fluff I think that's
it it's a pretty nice little multi-agent
sample as a
standalone okay here is our
snake
yeah this should just
be puffer Li
snake we'll discuss titling of stuff
later I might do like contributor names
or something on titles this one was mine
though I just this is the one that I
made okay that's nice and Speedy uh and
also that was the speed running locally
uh single core so this should be plenty
fast with mcrip in I hope we will
see uh resolution should be good
everything should be good
so I now should just be able to
do
[Music]
HTML forgot you got to you have to
install
okay so now we have our snake
build
and if I
just build web
snake uh and then I just
take game
Star and then I just go to Doc docker
oh hold
on I uh forgot that I had don't have it
there yet I have to install the the
docks
machine docs are open source as well if
you want to fix anything you can just PR
stuff to it hey when you're done what
piece can you
give okay yeah yeah yeah one second uh
let me let me copy this over and then I
will go ahead and do
that let me also get these things off of
my
camera
absolutely uh post a little more about
your background while you're there so I
will I'll tell her to you I have like a
few different resources depending on
where you're at at the
moment
dos set
okay here are our docks and let's see if
uh snake deployed
correctly uh yes it did did so we can
see we have the whole thing I don't have
rendering correct on the website
perfectly I got to fix resolution but
this is the updated version of the game
live in browser with a very easy and
quick deployment if I push the repo
it'll immediately be live on the main
site so to answer your question here um
what pie can you give it about a two to
two of five level on where we on where
are we with this
so really high level right puffer lib is
the library that I wish existed during
my PhD to make reinforcement learning
fast and same it has a very high
emphasis
on uh very fast simulators so we have
games environments other things that we
use to test reinforcement learning
algorithms and conduct research but in
puffer lib they run a thousand times
faster than basically everywhere else
and they're really really simple to
implement so like there are a few people
who have kind of figured out how to make
fast environments as well but they're
mostly using these like really Arcane
methods that require tons and tons of
experience to build um we are writing
environments in a way that is so simple
that any like undergrad and CS who has
taken a single systems course can
immediately jump in and start
contributing and in fact we have a lot
of Open Source contributors in the
Discord discord.gg puffer so if you're
looking to get into this stuff it's a
very very easy way to jump in and I
review all the code contributions
personally as well so there's that uh
that's one side of it fast environments
another side is experimental so if you
have fast environment what can you do
with it uh we have hyperparameter sweep
Integrations with carbs which is a very
nice algorithm for running tons of
experiments and finding optimal settings
we've been playing around with that it's
been very effective for very quick L
allowing us to get good policies on a
wide variety of different environments
but really that side of it is early on
and it's after this update that I'm
working on right now which is all the
environments that we're going to really
dig more into the science side and try
to figure out all of the rough edges
with reinforcement learning why does it
feel so hard to train stuff you know why
is everything so fiddly what knobs
matter matter that's going to be science
side and that's what's coming next other
things I done include really high
performance parallel simulation Tech
I've built that for puffer lib I've
built really good compatibility layers
uh I've built like lots of convenient
stuff there's a really nice Dev
container that just simplifies all the
setup uh lots of just like quality of
life tools for research or stuff like
that really just trying to make
reinforcement learning into a mature and
stable field with simple high
performance Reliable
Tools that is what I'm
doing in addition to contributing to
puffer Li itself I also have published a
few resources for beginners I mean most
of my work is aimed at pushing the field
forward it's not necessarily aimed at
being educational though it's turned out
that a lot of it has been just because
the way I'm building stuff it's very
easy to get into uh so this RL quick
start guide that's just on my Twitter J
5341 free to get that there I think I've
also pushed it
to yeah it's also now on the website but
it's on um it's on like the dev
website so it's like puffer ai.
github.io puffer doai it's there it'll
be at just puffer doai once I push
everything to the next update all the
websites are getting moved to puffer
doai so that's what I'm
doing hopefully that's helpful
yeah so this is the wrong rest
12 is it 1280 is that
res 640 *
2 1287 I think this is
it real resource most helpful with your
Iceberg thank you I put a lot of effort
into that video and not a lot of people
watched it like that was 80 hours of
work so I hope some people got some use
out of that sent me learning the code
wasn't introduced to AI through that way
how much will I need to
run environments so
um in order to get into
developing it goes as
fast in one video where you said it goes
as fast as the frame rate I'm not sure
what specifically you're referring to
there um to get into environment Dev
it's not like a beginner topic beginner
beginner topic but we've got like we
brought it down from you need a PhD to
do anything remotely useful down to like
you need to have a single course in
systems so we're writing most stuff in C
uh you need to know you need to know
what Malik does you need to know what a
pointer is you need to know like basic
loops and conditionals and stuff like
that and the most important thing is
just writing simple code without making
a mess of things we have a lot of
examples uh and it is a really great way
to learn it's a pretty fun way way to
learn as well um I generally for people
who are like brand brand new to CS in
general not just to AI I generally
suggest spending like 80% of your time
just coding stuff and then 20% of your
time on formal learning formal resources
I don't know
why the resolution is so janky on
here so we got width is 6 40 so
1280 1280 by 720
12872 could just be getting cashed or
something because this is definitely not
the right aspect
ratio oh see there it goes I think
there's just some weird thing going on
with the
JavaScript oh yeah if you hold shift I'm
controlling this guy right
here yeah cool and if I just take my
hand off the keyboard the AI takes over
for
you very
nice
um okay so this is
done I want to fix pong and breakout
baselines uh those should be very easy
to do I believe
here we'll let this play for a little
bit to make sure this is the good
going so while I've just been doing this
so far we've run these experiments and
here are the results so
far looks like most of these runs that
do decently are in the same sort of
score range of six points which I need
to I don't understand the game enough to
know how good that
is uh yeah this is definitely the good
policy look at this thing this is way
better at breakout than I
am I could not do this
look at that it even got the uh it's
actually trying to do that I'm pretty
sure it's actually learned to try to
bounce it like that like look it's like
bouncing it against the left wall to try
to like specifically get that I think at
least I've seen it do it enough times it
makes me think it's not
accidental it's not like perfect at it
by any means but it's pretty
good it's like so close it to be fair
that's a pretty tricky thing to pull off
relaunch to make sure it gets the right
files
yeah okay let's get the I think we have
one for pong as well to make uh new pong
Baseline
good you can see this one's playing very
well this is definitely the right model
it's lost one life it has has almost
cleared first screen
nice one of the perks of uh building the
library so I can make the puffer live
the
ball and the
puffer it's the
ball for
okay I think I even have to reboot it
but just to be sure it doesn't Cash
It Here is the new pawn policy I think I
think this one is correct the new one is
more like jittery oh it lost a point
there though hold
on it sometimes will lose a point but
very
rarely let's watch it for a second make
sure it's actually the good
fluke 10
Bill who made a 10
B no I didn't
10 oh 10 Bill model on a Ras
um that would be very
slow oh and you can't no you're not I
don't know what you're doing you're
definitely not pre-training a 10 Bill
model on a Raspberry Pi maybe they like
did a tiny amount of fine tuning or
something
I know I really don't follow llm space
hon because it's like there's just a lot
of [ __ ] in it at the this
point I used to work in language
modeling like long time ago
before Transformers were a
thing okay yeah this is definitely the
right policy cool so pong's updated
breakouts updated snake is
updated I think the Connect 4 one we may
as
well uh
web I think we have to copy the Connect
4 one as well
significantly why
[ __ ] this just happens to any field
that starts to blow up massively right
all the money started being an llm so
all like the nft and crypto shells came
over to Ai and like you know if you've
been in the field for a long time you
know who's legit and who's not but if
you're a newcomer to Tech like you're
not going to know who is just scamming
you and who's just spreading [ __ ] so
it's just not a fun place
anymore for my own
purposes I also just preferentially I
don't like to work in wellestablished
capital intensive areas if I can avoid
it like I can do so so so much more in
RL right now than I can do in language
modeling
uses open
AI what's
uses I mean it's fine to sort of drift
around and like check out a bunch of
different stuff in AI
days it's a humongous
mug this is currently
for where is it the experiment that I've
been doing this week which was the
Thousand calorie breakfast
mug it's like hot chocolate with 76
grams of protein that I've been trying
to make not taste terrible
okay you can hold shift to like stop it
so I'm just seeing if it's actually
winning baselines uploaded for these uh
1 2 3 4
environments MOA needs the Baseline uh
it's already has a train version I just
need to make the final thing to upload I
mean it's pretty much the same as what's
on here now this m is actually pretty
good probably going to make this one so
that you take so that uh it plays by
default instead of you having to take
over this is a fun environment though I
really like this
one so then pretty much this will all be
done and and this and then Spencer's
fixing this rware should be pretty easy
triple Triad looking
decent as
well I don't actually know how many
points you can realistically get is the
thing I wish I knew like a upper bound
on how well you could
right okay so that'll be live on the
website in a few
minutes it
pushes I could have sworn I
had credentials tracking hold on
this this is the
WB
sweep um that is running tons of
different experiments on Triple Triad
right now in order to determine optimal
experimental settings
oh that was
weird
whatever okay so this is now pushed and
then in a couple of minutes uh it will
show up
here with the latest
policies so these are all now these are
all done and then for release we need
triple Triad go Spencer got go and
probably
rware uh I can probably start messing
with the
see that should be pretty
easy 250
mil I don't know if this is the latest
set I think this is the latest param set
let's
see buffer
MOBA a lot of this is just release work
right like we have most of the
experiments done and things just need to
be run on the
latest no Cuda gpus available what the
hell that is
bizarre didn't I just
train I just trained this a bit
ago with Cuda
I was going to run this in the
background I probably can't fix that
error without rebooting this probably
just needs a reboot it probably just
updated something in the
background shouldn't really be doing but
whatever
so this will
run I need to get Baseline for Moa that
shouldn't take very long what about
rware yeah I don't think that there's
much else I do on these I think Spencer
has got both of these and then there's
just Xander
has Xander has his trash pickup
environment that he's going to finish B
has his Enduro end let me actually just
send some quick messages while I'm here
on these people just to get
status updates
and
then I think Noah had
cool uh for folks watching here like
these are all just people who've jumped
in here and been like yeah let's code on
some RL environments
um
so like Spencer made go Connect 4 and
rware Nathan did puffer tactics and I
believe pong Noah did
Breakout oh yeah Spencer also did triple
Triad uh I did snake MOA and this TCG
prototype that needs some work that Noah
is looking at now a couple other people
like I think David did uh AI opponents
scripted opponents for Connect 4 no Jake
did that and then David did um like
improve physics for breakout we got all
the contributors list where is it yeah
contributors listed
here but yeah if you're interested uh we
need more M we need work done on
existing M there's like this Robo code
like this robot tank M that needs to go
on here still lots and lots of
additional work
interesting so if you look at score
curves here it's
like they still go up just a little
little
bit I don't know what optimal
is I actually don't know what optimal
play
is I think I let this run for a little
longer though it's unlikely that
um it's unlikely that this is as good as
it can do so I'll let this run a little
bit and then we'll come back this
afternoon I'll probably just take
whatever has done here in a few hours um
I might get a Robo code prototype onto
the website there's some website stuff
to fix and I'll probably just do that
while I let docs run in the
meantime that'll probably be good I'm
trying to think if there's anything I
can do right
now I can probably start on
docs be a good thing to do so I have
this Doc Page uh this is live you're
free to look at it it's just that this
is you
know extension
uh until it's
deployed formally and uh it's a pretty
good tutorial but I haven't tested any
of the code here at
all so maybe that's what we'll
do of course I do need
the I need my NVIDIA drivers to work
I don't want to reboot this and kill the
stream
like 15 minutes 20 minutes before I'm
going to end
anyways maybe if I just reboot Docker
that'll be enough
lib ah that actually worked okay just a
little background
annoyance
so in that case what we're going to
do uh we're going to do two things
training and then what we're going to do
is we're just going to prep this
command so that when I uh before I leave
I run this Baseline it's only like a 12
minute run I
believe but I will cue that
up and then before then I will work on
this
and we'll start
on the
what's the default thing
do I think it just runs train on puffer
squared
if you just run demo. Pi cool now it
actually does something it
trains and this gives you puffer Square
you type
help you get all of these
parameters you used to get M parameters
right like you get all these train
parameters but you don't get M
happen did I get rid of that feature I
didn't think I
did hi I haven't seen a stream in a
couple months how are things are
progressing things are progressing quite
well so what happened there was uh I
moved
not moved I mean I'm like I travel
seasonally but I went from California to
Florida and I didn't have a desktop and
it took way longer to get one shipped
than I expected so I just got everything
set up this week um this is like I've
only done a couple streams since then
but now most of my development is going
to be back to being streamed uh we're
nearing the next release we've got a
nice demo website this is live though
it's at this you know this weird URL for
now and uh it's got tons of stuff on it
so we've got all the M's they're
playable we've got new docs this is
Local Host version so we've got new docs
that I'm currently testing there's a
Blog again Local Host not live there
blog uh there's a business thing there's
a homepage there's all this
stuff so yeah gearing up for
release a lot of work but it's been good
I hope to do a lot more of this stuff
live
now my camera just freeze
again I'm absolutely going to have to
get a new new
camera or figure out what's wrong with
drivers it's probably drivers to be
honest I wonder if its Graphics crash
you know
do you think my Nvidia driver still
works
now okay Invidia driver still works so
it's just a it's not a graphics thing
it's just a weird camera bug that's
fine how am I populating help menu
amazing to see steady work inspiring
hope things continue I hope so too going
pretty well for
poer been going pretty well for buer I'm
pretty much just doing
uh I'm just doing like tons of exercise
and building puffer and nothing else
that's pretty much my schedule these
days trying to get in really good shape
Pi RL every everything else is kind of
small
potatoes I don't know I've had a few fun
things I've been doing
lately I really like this stupid side
project that I started this
week I was I've been trying to figure
out how to make like a decent thousand
calorie breakfast
mug I have
the open source breakfast with patch
notes for each version
I thought there used to be like an
inspect th000 calories
DSE yeah the goal is to have something
it
like I need like 3,000 plus calories per
day and I do not have the appetite for
3,000 calories a day so
this helps I've been trying to figure
out how to do this for a while and it's
actually it's really hard to get
something like they're very very few
things that are actually calorie dense
enough uh but recently heavy cream heavy
cream is just about the only thing that
fits the
bill and then the key is to figure out
how I can get uh protein powder to mix
reasonably well with heavy cream uh
without just being like a sludge mess so
I've been working on that
I'm probably going to look into like
some basics of uh like suspension
chemistry like how people making premix
drinks how they get stuff to work in
suspension that's probably going to be
the
next thing I do with it for now I've
just been fine-tuning the recipe a
little bit here and
there I've been playing around with
whether or not I want it to have added
sugar I think it needs a little added
sugar just it's really disgusting
otherwise do you have a goal in mind for
fitness health I mean yeah I do at the
moment I do a hybrid between running
training and strength training for the
most part and I do different stuff in
different blocks so over the summer I
did a really heavy endurance block I
trained for and I ran a
50k and uh I got my 1,000 lb
total now I'm trying to do
uh more like an athleticism focused
block so I'm trying to get my 5K time
down like my shorter run times to be a
lot faster uh while keeping or gaining
weight and keeping strength
on so that's been the current Endeavor
it's been going decently I've got
my 5K down it's like
20 like
2540 or 20 6 minutes something like that
uh my high school best was 20 like 2140
or something but I weighed 45 lb less or
50 lbs less then so I'm trying to match
my high school time at like while
weighing 50 lbs
more is going to be the goal
all tangential are you on Blue Sky n
stayed on
X I generally I like X um I don't really
see the point of people moving to Blue
Sky like there have been a ton of these
and none of them really work over X and
like if you look at a lot of the stuff
that X is doing it's kind of fine like
whoops stupid cam
camera
like like any platform where you can
fact check the person who owns the
platform is probably doing decent stuff
you
know so I think that people will
probably be back to X for the most part
pretty soon
social media is really obnoxious as is
it's like a colossal waste of time
outside of the uh you know the growth on
projects and stuff so I'd like I don't
really want to have a second platform to
have to do stuff on and the audience is
going to be much larger on x
what happened
here I could have sworn I had something
I had a piece of code that would give
you um help menu based on your
environment I don't remember if I
deleted it
gotcha yeah no
worries and I'm on stream to broadcast
work and chat with people it's
fine uh I don't have inspect in here
either how was I
getting I'm confused how was I getting
this there was like a dynamic help menu
I get in it ARS right here so is there
do I use this get in it okay so I don't
actually use this anymore
yeah okay so here it
is
um make
and
Creator well M Creator is so I have this
make
M but this make M should
partial so why you don't use stupid
functional
things it's my camera's still
crashing I'm going to have to fix that
later that's super obnoxious
okay I know what needs to be fixed there
though
on so
um I'm going to head to uh gym for a bit
I'm going to be back a few
hours um we got new policies
uploaded uh to the website so you can
actually already play around with these
here I think you should be able to see
like is this the new snake yeah this is
the new snake their rendering resolution
is inconsistent it's not always correct
I got to fix
that um we also have this sweep running
on Triple
Triad I'm going to launch this one right
now on my local
machine after I remove that break
point okay so this will run our MOA
Baseline so we should get that uh we'll
see with triple Triad we'll see if we
have a baseline for that we will
apparently not be able to have a working
camera
um I don't know I'll figure that out
later today it's super laggy as well I
can tell so that's weird um but yeah I
will look at that stuff and then when I
get back I will start going through docs
and cleaning that page up because pretty
much just environments baselines and
docks and we should be good so uh thanks
folks join the Discord discord.gg
puffer and I'll be back in the afternoon
if you want to support the project it's
all open source and free just go ahead
and star the repository github.com
puffer AI puffer lib I'll put that in
the
chat is engineer Arts [ __ ] I have no
idea what that is I've never heard that
word so
probably um yeah see you around back in
a few hours